HARD EARNED MILESTONE NIGHT F F
THAT.
QUINN HUGHES IN HIS FIRST GAME
AGAINST TORONTO THIS YEAR WASE .
AND DAVID KAMPF, TRYING TO PLAY
IT AWAY FROM PEARSON.
GAVE IT UP.
GAME, FIRST SHOT WAS A REBOUND
THERE FOR THE TAKING.
MILLER WINS THE BATTLE.
LEAFS ALL AROUND HIM, BUT MILLE
.
EARLIER ON HE LOOKED TO PASS.
THAT TIM
HERE'S HORVAT AND CAMPBELL CAME
ACROSS AND MADE A STOP.
WHEN HORVAT LOOKED LIKE HEOUT T
WATCH BOESER IMMEDIATELY JUST
TURN AND GET AWAY FROM CAMPBELL.
HE GETS A LITTLE
TOWARDS MILLER, AND NOW NYLANDER
SK JOB OF GETTING
TO THAT AND PASS T T
PUT THEM IN SITUATIONS WHERE
THEY LOSE THEIR CONFIDENCE BUT
BECAUSE OF INJURY IT'S BEEN THAT
MUCH MORE ONE
END, AND INTERESTING TO GET ADV.
TAVARES A GOAL AND AN ASSIST ON
INSTEAD IT GOES TOO IECE OF
THAT.
AGAIN NO STICK FORWAYS EASY TO
THIS SITUATION.
LOOKOK IN BEHIND THE NET.
J.T. MILLER AFTER IT.
YOU REMEMBER THE BOESER
TURNOVER.
WE GET A CHANCE TO MAKE
AND HE HOPES THEY CAN AUTHOR THE
SAME SCRIPT AS A COUPLE OF
NIGHTS AGO
>> Craig: THAT'S HOCKEY, ISN EV.
DON'T PASS UP A SHOT ANYWHERE T
LEAFS COME UP WIT
A STRETCH PASS FOR BUNTING.
CRUISING AT THE VANCOUVER LINE.,
THERE'S THE STICK GONE.
NOW MLIFTED AND OUT COMES PETTE.
ELIAS PETTERSSON HAS HORVAT WITH
HIHI
TY D